knappen Zeit fünf Nachfragen ich bitte
um Verständnis wenn ich dann cut mache
nach fünf Fragen ich versuche es mir zu
merken die Hände gehen schon hoch
Annalena Bernburg hat das Wort
schönen guten Tag auf von meiner Seite
jetzt sind zwei drei Tage nach der Wahl
wir leiten aus dem Wahlergebnis einen
klaren Auftrag ab Verantwortung für die
Zukunft unseres Landes zu übernehmen und
eine progressive Regierung zu bilden
dass es nicht nur ein besonderer Moment
für unsere Partei sondern auch für
dieses Land erstmalig für drei Parteien
gemeinsam Gespräche über die Zukunft und
auch über die Erneuerung unseres Landes
dafür haben wir jetzt alle Weichen
entsprechend gestellt haben gestern
schon gemeinsam mit der FDP vertraulich
gesprochen werden das am Freitag dann
noch mal in größerer Runde fortsetzen
zwischen grün und der FDP um dann am
Samstag unseren eigenen kleinen
Parteitag zu haben wo wir alle weiteren
Schritte für diese Sondierungsgespräche
und für die Bildung einer möglichen
Regierung in die Wege zu leiten auch mit
Blick auf weitere sondierungsteam und
mit neueren und weiteren Zeitplan und
dann am Sonntag gemeinsam mit der SPD am
Abend ebenfalls Gespräche zu führen mit
der Union stehen wir auch im Kontakt
aber der Auftrag den wir haben ist ein
klarer Auftrag für eine Erneuerung in
unserem Land und in diesem Sinne werden
wir auch in den nächsten Tagen daran
arbeiten die Grundlagen für eine
progressive Regierung in Deutschland zu
bilden
und zwar einmal würden sie Jamaika unter
einem möglichen Verhandlungsführer und
dann auch Kanzler Söder ausschließen und
meine kleine Frage wie geht es Ihnen
jetzt drei Tage nach der Wahl
okay vielleicht bei der zweiten Frage
angefangen nach sieben Wochen intensivem
Wahlkampf und jetzt der direkten
Vorbereitung für die Gespräche dafür
eine neue Regierung zu bilden und
Verantwortung in diesem Land zu
übernehmen ist der Schlaf natürlich
nicht deutlich mehr geworden aber jetzt
sind die Weichen dafür zu stellen
wirklich inhaltlich sich darauf zu
fokussieren wie wir eine nächste
Regierung bilden können und wie ich ja
gerade deutlich gemacht habe sprechen
wir jetzt zuerst vor allem mit der FDP
und dann mit der SPD da liegen
entsprechende nicht nur Einladung
sondern genaue Gesprächstermine ja auch
schon vor und die Union hat uns heute
eingeladen auch zu Gesprächen dann in
nächster Woche und da muss man dann in
die genauere Planung noch gehen
und Söders wir haben ja noch nicht mal
mit der Union gesprochen wie gesagt wir
sprechen jetzt erstmal mit FDP und SPD
eigentlich jamaika ist für sie so gut
wie vom Tisch für unsere trotzdem noch
Gespräch und die zweite Frage wie lange
soll diese vorsorgen gehen bevor sie
entscheiden dass sie in echte
Sondierungen über 50
pensionsvolutionspartner geben mit dem
Gespräche werden damals geführt werden
wenn der schon eine zweite Runde führen
mit der SPD
ja 2017 sollte sich nicht wiederholen
deswegen ist unser Anspruch wirklich
jetzt zügig Gespräche zu führen und auch
vertrauensvollgespräche zu führen
deswegen auch zum gestrigen Abend oder
weitere Gespräche ist unsere herzliche
Einladung an alle anderen Parteien aber
auch an uns dass es wirklich in
Vertraulichkeit stattfindet weil die
weichen die man stellen will die sind ja
wirklich große Erneuerung für dieses
Land das heißt auch Projekte die man
angeht die man bisher in diesem Land
noch nicht angegangen ist gemeinsam
auszuloten und das braucht eine
Vertraulichkeit aber es bedeutet auch
dass ich Sondierungen nicht über Wochen
gar Monate hinziehen können sondern dass
diese Sondierung dann zügig vonstatten
gehen und wir haben bereits im Wahlkampf
deutlich gemacht wir haben auch am
Wahlabend deutlich gemacht nachdem klar
war dass die SPD diese Wahl gewonnen hat
dass wir zuerst Gespräche mit SPD und
FDP führen werden und vor allen Dingen
dass wir in Auftrag für eine progressive
Regierung haben um dieses Land steuern
aber dass wir natürlich mit allen
demokratischen Parteien sprechen
Sonntag führen sie gemeinsam entsprechen
de fdp-gruppen
das hat der Wissing heute ja auch schon
deutlich gemacht am Sonntag spricht erst
die FDP mit der SPD und dann sprechen
wir Grünen mit der SPD
[Musik]
hat ja schon kenntlich gemacht dass sie
Jamaica präferieren also eine Führung
der Union wenn sich dann dementsprechend
entgegen dass es ihnen mit Herrn Scholz
lieber wäre und wenn man dann irgendwann
im gemeinsamen Verhandlung einsteigt ist
dann davon auszugehen dass man damit
einem gemeinsamen grünen eben Entwurf
auf die anderen beiden zugeht
zur ersten Frage hatte ich ja eben schon
deutlich gemacht dass wir gerade im
sozialpolitischen Bereich natürlich
große Schnittmengen mit der SPD haben
die SPD ist der Wahlsieger nach dieser
Bundestagswahl und deswegen ist es für
uns auch zentral diese Gespräche jetzt
zuallererste zu führen aber wir reden
wie gesagt mit allen Parteien und der
zweite Punkt mit Blick auf SPD mit FDP
und äh Grüne haben wir am Wahlabend ja
auch schon deutlich gemacht dass wir
zuerst miteinander sprechen auch
vertraulich sprechen weil zum einen
dieser Auftrag an uns ist dass wir eine
wirkliche Erneuerung angehen und es mit
Blick auf die FDP ja auch Bereiche gibt
wo man eben eine Erneuerung gerade im
gesellschaftspolitischen Bereich
gemeinsam gestalten kann und auf der
anderen Seite
bekanntermaßen es Themen gibt wo man
doch sehr weit auseinander steht und
eben auszuloten wo man Brücken bauen
kann und wo man gemeinsam dieses Land
eigentlich nicht nur 21 Jahrhundert
bringen kann sondern die Weichen für die
Zukunft zu stellen kann das halten wir
für sinnvoll und haben das am Wahlabend
ja auch schon deutlich gemacht
also haben sie schon Brücken bauen
können Sie vertraulich wahr ist wenn
jemand von Vertrauen aufbauen sprechen
ist das gestern Abend schon gelungen und
in welcher Größe Treffen am Sonntag mit
der SPD wie viele Kabinen werden da
teilnehmen
wir hätten gestern ein gutes Gespräch
und wenn ich jetzt drei Sätze mehr sage
dann ist es nicht mehr vertraulich
deswegen dieses Gespräch bleibt
vertraulich so wie andere Gespräche auch
vertraulich bleiben werden und wir
werden aber und das ist ja dann wenn die
Sondierung richtig beginnen auch mit
unserem Parteitag natürlich bei größeren
Gesprächen dann entsprechend auch
deutlich machen wer daran teilnimmt wann
diese Gespräche stattfinden wenn die
Gespräche dann wie gesagt offiziell
beginnen und dazu kann sonst auch unser
Geschäftsführer später auch noch mal was
sagen wir haben den antragsentwurf für
unseren Parteitag gerade eben auch
versteckt wo unser sondierungsteam mit
zehn Personen benannt wird was dann bei
größeren Runden entsprechend diese
Gespräche führen wird
vielen Dank den Antrag müssten Sie in
Kürze auch im Netz finden wir können ihn
gerne auch noch mal zuschicken so dass
sie dort auch die Namen entsprechend
haben und alle Informationen die Sie
hoffentlich brauchen sonst melden Sie
sich gerne noch mal wenn es Detailfragen
gibt ja vielen Dank